GOOD AFTERNOON EVERYBODY.
WE ARE GOING TO GO AHEAD AND GET
STARTED BECAUSE WE'D LIKE TO GET
OUT OF HERE AS SOON AS POSSIBLE
[inaudible]
SO -- I HAVE THE SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
IRWIN YOUR VOEPEL [inaudible]
BOERNER HORVATH [inaudible]
OBERNOLTE.
DALY.
FRAZIER.
GLORIA [inaudible]
MATHIS [inaudible]
MURATSUCHI [inaudible]
NORRIS [inaudible]
SALAS.
ALL RIGHT AND WE ARE GOING TO
THE FIRST THING WE'RE GONNA DO
IS IT OFF THE COMMITTEE RULES
CAN I HAVE A MOTION SO SEC.
SO -- MOTION BY A DALY SECOND BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SALAS -- VOTE
PLEASE -- WHEN?
HI -- WHEN I VOEPEL?
VOEPEL AYE BOERNER HORVATH.
BOERNER HORVATH I OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE I A DAILY.
DALY AYE FRAZIER.
GLORIA.
GLORIA AYE MATHIS.
MURATSUCHI [inaudible]
PETRIE-NORRIS.
PETRIE-NORRIS I SALAS SALAS AYE.
EIGHT ALL RIGHT THAT.
OKAY -- YOU KNOW WHAT WE'RE
GONNA DO WE'RE GOING TO GO AHEAD
AND START WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER
VOEPEL -- AB
[inaudible]
ONE SIXTY GOOD AFTERNOON.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER VOEPEL.
MADAM CHAIR COLLEAGUES.
TODAY I HAVE THE PLEASURE
PRESIDING AB ONE SIXTY A BILL
THAT WILL ALLOW A PRIVATE
EMPLOYER THE ABILITY TO ENACT A
VOLUNTARY VETERANS PREFERENCE
PROGRAM.
THE VOLUNTARY VETERANS
PREFERENCE IS RECOGNIZE AND
ENJOYED AMONG PUBLIC EMPLOYERS
HOWEVER PRIVATE EMPLOYERS ARE
LIMITED TO ONLY VIETNAM WAR ERA
VETERANS WHEN EXERCISING THEIR
VOLUNTARY.
VETERANS PREFERENCE AND TELL YOU
THE TRUTH THERE'S NOT A WHOLE
LOT OF VIETNAM VETERANS MY AGE.
LOOKING FOR A JOB.
AB ONE SIXTY SIMPLY REVISES THE
OUTDATED OVERSIGHT BY ALLOWING
PRIVATE EMPLOYERS TO EXERCISE A
VOLUNTARY VETERANS PREFERENCE.
TO ALL VETERANS WITH THE GENERAL
OR HONORABLE DISCHARGE
REGARDLESS OF THE ERA IN WHICH
THEY SERVED.
SIMILAR VOLUNTARY VETERANS
PERFORMANCE PROGRAMS HAVE BEEN
ENACTED IN THIRTY SEVEN STATES
ACROSS THE COUNTRY AND HAVE
MANAGED TO STAY COMPLIANT WITH
THE CIVIL RIGHTS ACT OF NINETEEN
SIXTY FOUR WHICH PROHIBITS
DISCRIMINATION IN HIRING.
THERE'S NO REASON CALIFORNIA
SHOULD NOT BE CAPABLE OF THE
SAME.
I HAVE A WHAT IS BETTER CHAIR.
MY NAME'S JULIE WORLEY AND I AM
AN HR CONSULTANT HERE IN THE
SACRAMENTO AREA.
I AM THE PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT DIRECTOR FOR THE
CALIFORNIA.
SYSOP STATE WELL THE CALIFORNIA
STATE COUNCIL THE SOCIETY FOR
HUMAN RESOURCE MANAGEMENT.
I'M A MEMBER AND A PAST
PRESIDENT OF THE SACRAMENTO AREA
HUMAN RESOURCE ASSOCIATION.
AND THE H. R. PROFESSION IS
EXTREMELY AND KEENLY AWARE OF
THE STRUGGLES THAT OUR MEN AND
WOMEN.
FACE WHEN THEY ARE ENTERING THE
WORK FORCE AFTER DEPLOYMENT OR
THEIR TERM IS BEING VETERANS.
CAL SHERMAN AND THE SOCIETY FOR
HUMAN RESOURCE MANAGEMENT HAVE A
LONG COMMITMENT IN HIRING OUR
NATION'S VETERANS.
BOTH ORGANIZATIONS HAVE
PARTNERSHIPS AND CONDUCTED
EDUCATION AND OUTREACH
ACTIVITIES TO PROMOTE THE HIRING
OF VETERANS.
AND WE BELIEVE THAT MORE SHOULD
BE DONE TO MAKE IT EASIER FOR
EMPLOYERS TO HIRE VETERANS.
AND ALLOW AN EMPLOYER TO
EXERCISE A VOLUNTARY HIRING
PREFERENCE EXCEPTION. FOR ALL
VETERANS IS ONE SMALL WAY WE CAN
FACILITATE HIRING.
AB ONE SIXTIES ESTABLISHMENT OF
A VOLUNTARY PREFERENCE POLICY.
FOR EMPLOYERS IS A FAIR AND
MEANINGFUL WAY TO ASSIST
VETERANS IN OBTAINING GAINFUL
EMPLOYMENT.
WHILE SHIELDING THOSE EMPLOYERS
WHO EXERCISE THIS PREFERENCE
FROM A POTENTIAL CLAIM OF
DISCRIMINATION.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND
SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL.
THANK YOU AND DO WE HAVE ANY
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THE BILL.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS -- MY NAME IS SET THREE
WITH THREE GOVERNMENT RELATIONS.
AND REPRESENTING AMERICAN LEGION
DEPARTMENT CALIFORNIA AMVETS
DEPARTMENT OF CALIFORNIA
CALIFORNIA STATE COMMANDERS.
VETERANS COUNCIL MILITARY
OFFICERS ASSOCIATION OF AMERICA
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL OF CHAPTERS
NATIONAL GUARD ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA AND VIçT NAM
VETERANS.
OF AMERICA CALIFORNIA STATE
COUNCIL ON SUPPORT OF THIS.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
JESSE VALLEJO WITH THE CIVIL
JUSTICE SOCI ASIAN CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT.
FREDERICK RHOEMETALCES ME.
CAN J. I. FORM OF CALIFORNIA
WE'RE SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
THANKS THANK YOU ANY WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION
.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
MARIE CARRIERS ARE WHAT THEY
CALIFORNIAN PLUMMET LAWYERS
ASSOCIATION -- APPRECIATE THE
INTENT BEHIND THE BILL AND IT'S
REALLY UNFORTUNATE TO BE HERE IN
OPPOSITION OUR ATTORNEYS.
REPRESENT SERVICE MEMBERS AND
VETERANS AND DISCRIMINATION YOU
SERRA AND STATE EQUIVALENT TYPE
CLAIMS.
ARE ISSUE WITH THIS BILL IF YOU
KIND OF TAKE A STEP BACK AND
LOOK AT THE PURPOSE BEHIND IT
WHY WE NEED TO AMEND OUR AND
THIS DISCRIMINATION LAWS TO
ALLOW FOR THIS KIND OF VETERANS
PREFERENCE HIRING POLICY.
IS BECAUSE WITHOUT SUCH EXPLICIT
AUTHORIZATION IT DOES ACTUALLY
VIOLATE OUR INTO DISCRIMINATION
LAWS.
AND THE REASON WHY IS BECAUSE HI
THAT KIND OF VETERANS PREFERENCE
POLICY HAS A DISPARATE IMPACT ON
WOMEN.
AND ALSO -- INDIVIDUALS FROM THE
LGBT COMMUNITY ON THE EEOC HAS
ACTUALLY TAKEN A SPECIFIC STANCE.
EXPLAINING HOW A VETERANS HIRING
POLICY DOES HAVE A DISPARATE
IMPACT ON THOSE INDIVIDUALS.
AND SO FOR THOSE REASONS --
AGAIN WOMEN MAKE UP MAKE UP JUST
10% OF VETERANS AND BECAUSE OF
THE HISTORICAL AN ONGOING
EXCLUSIONARY POLICIES.
FOR LGBT INDIVIDUALS WHO WANT
WHO WANT TO SERVE -- WE AGAIN
ARE FOR THAT THIS WILL HAVE A
DISPARATE IMPACT ON ON THOSE
INDIVIDUALS THAT ALSO NEED.
REMOVAL OF BARRIERS TO
EMPLOYMENT.
YEAH BUT I'M SURE KEVIN BAKER
FROM THE CONCERT LIBERTIES UNION
OF CALIFORNIA ALSO AND
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION THAT
NUMBER OF CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
AUTHOR OF THE YEAR -- OBVIOUSLY
ISSUE IS VERY COMMITTED TO
ADDRESSING THE NEEDS OF VETERANS --
IT ON A LOT OF DIFFERENT FRONTS --
AND WE APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S
INTEREST IN IN DOING EVERYTHING
HE CAN -- TO TO ADDRESS THOSE
IMPORTANT NEEDS ON IT GETS
TRICKY HOWEVER WHEN WE START
SINGLING OUT ONE GROUP THAT IS
CURRENTLY PROTECTED UNDER THE
FIRM PLANS HAVE.
HOUSING ACT.
LIKE OTHER GROUPS AND SAVE THOSE
THAT ONE PARTICULAR GROUP CAN BE
GRANTED PREFERENTIAL TREATMENT
OVER OTHERS AND JUSTIFYING
INTENTIONAL DISCRIMINATION.
SO THAT I THINK IS THE
DIFFICULTY I THINK THERE ARE
OTHER THINGS WE CAN AND SHOULD
DO TO ADDRESS THE EMPLOYMENT
NEEDS OF OUR VETERANS BUT I
DON'T THINK THIS IS A LIFE STEP.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
TAMMY MARTIN WITH EQUALITY
CALIFORNIA ALSO RESPECTFULLY IN
OPPOSITION.
RIGHT DO WE HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
FROM THE PANEL.
NOW ALL RIGHT WE HAD A MOTION BY --
I'M SORRY.
REMEMBER GLORIA SURE THERE WOULD
BE OTHERS BESIDES ME OF THIS
VOEPEL GOOD TO SEE SIR THIS IS
VERY SIMILAR TO PIECE OF
LEGISLATION THAT YOU HAD IN THE
LAST -- BUT HE SAID SESSION
SESSION CRACKED -- AT THAT TIME --
I'D RAISE CONCERNS TO YOU ABOUT
THE ODDITY COMMUNITY -- AND THE
POTENTIAL FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE
DESERVING OF THIS KIND OF
PREFERENCE TO NOT BE ABLE TO
ACCESS IT BECAUSE OF OUR STATED
OUR NATION'S OUTDATED -- DON'T
ASK DON'T TELL POLICIES CAN TALK
ABOUT -- HOW THIS BILL?
BIG CONSIDERS THOSE KINDS OF
VETERANS POLICY GIVEN THE
CONCERNS OF A QUALITY CALIFORNIA
THIS AFTERNOON.
YES SIR.
THIS BILL TREATS ALL VETERANS
EQUALLY [inaudible]
AND I DON'T HAVE NUMBERS ON THE
LGBT COMMUNITY IN THE MILITARY
BECAUSE THEY DON'T TRACK IT.
THEY TREAT EVERYONE IN THE
MILITARY ABSOLUTELY EQUAL I DO
HAVE NUMBERS IF I MAY.
UM IN CALIFORNIA ONE THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN THOUSAND SEVEN HUNDRED
TWENTY NINE RECRUITS WERE
RECRUITED ACROSS THE FIVE
BRANCHES IN.
TWENTY SIXTEEN SO WE'RE NOT
TALKING ABOUT A GIANT AMOUNT OF
PEOPLE.
WOMEN MAKE UP CURRENTLY IN THE
MILITARY 16218% AND GROWING.
OKAY SO YOUR NUMBERS ARE A
LITTLE BIT.
OLD -- THEY ARE.
COMPRISING 9% OF THE UNITED
STATES VETERANS POPULATION BUT
MUCH HIGHER IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AMONG IN LISTED
RECRUITS. 43% OF MEN AND 56% OF
WOMEN ARE HISPANIC OR A RACIAL
MINORITY.
THAT'S HUGE THE MILITARY HAS
CHANGED IS CHANGE DRAMATICALLY
AND WOMEN.
ARE MUCH MORE DIVERSE THAN THE
MEN SO IT IS PRETTY DRAMATIC AND
I SEE WITHIN TEN YEARS WOMEN
COMPRISE AT LEAST 30% OF THE
MILITARY ESPECIALLY AS WE GO
INTO THE HIGH TECHNOLOGY AREAS.
I KEEP TRYING.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TO GET NUMBERS
ON LGBT Q. BECAUSE DON'T ASK
DON'T TELL IS OVER.
THE MILITARY'S OPEN THE ONLY
THING THEY'RE NOT DOING NOW IS
TRANS GENDER -- SURGERIES AND
THAT MAY CHANGE VERY WELL IN THE
FUTURE SO I WILL CONTINUE TO
PURSUE THAT I'VE ALWAYS BEEN.
CONFUSED WHY PEOPLE WOULD OPPOSE
THIS BILL AND ONE OF THE MAIN
REASONS FOR THIS BILL.
IS MOST OF THESE KIDS GRADUATED
FROM HIGH SCHOOL.
THEY DID THERE FOR YEARS THEY
COME BACK FROM AFGHANISTAN I
ROCK WHERE EVER WE SEND THEM.
THEY GET OUT OF THE MILITARY.
YOU GOT TO DO THREE THINGS FARO
AND IT'S SO IMPORTANT OTHERWISE
THEY SLIDE OFF THE RADAR SCOPE
NUMBER ONE THEY GOT TO GET A JOB.
THEY DON'T GET A JOB THERE ARE
DEEP TROUBLE.
THEY NEED.
TO GO TO SCHOOL USUALLY IT'S
COMMUNITY COLLEGE WE HAVE FINE.
COMMUNITY COLLEGE VETERAN
PROGRAMS AND THEY GOT TO STAY
OFF OF ABUSING DRUGS AND ALCOHOL
IF THEY DO THOSE THREE THINGS.
LIKE ME AS A VIETNAM VETERAN NAY
COULD BE SITTING HERE SOME DAY.
OR SUCCESSFUL IN BUSINESS KEEP
THEIR FAMILIES FIGHT PTSD UNLESS
YOU BETTER IN THE MILITARY YOU
DON'T KNOW WHAT IT'S LIKE TO GET
YOUR **** KICKED.
ALL OVER THE WORLD.
SO THAT'S I DON'T KNOW IF THAT
ANSWERS YOUR QUESTION.
AND THEN SOME.
VIA AND I JUST FOR THAT FOR THE
RECORD BE CLEAR THAT --
TRANSGENDER PEOPLE AMERICA
AMERICANS CANNOT SERVE IN THE
MILITARY GOV YOU KNOW KILEY
OBVIOUSLY AND SO IT'S NOT THAT
THE THAT OF MEDICAL PROCEDURES
AND ALLOW IT'S JUST THERE'S
ACTUAL SERVICE MILITARY NOT
ALLOWED SO THAT.
GETS COMPLICATED BUT I THINK THE
PREVIOUSLY WERE SHOT EXTREME
GOOD WILL AND TRYING TO BE
BROADLY INCLUSIVE OF FOLKS WHO
HAD HAVE A DISH CHARGES THAT
WERE NOT HONORABLE NOT BECAUSE
OF THEIR SERVICE BECAUSE OF WHO
THEY WERE AND REFLECTION THE
FACT ABOUT LAWS THAT CHANGE.
AND I THINK THAT YOU'D STILL
CONTINUE IN DENVER TO DO THAT
WITH THIS PIECE OF LEGISLATION.
YEAH I THINK I WANT TO RAISE THE
MENTION I THINK IT'S FAIR IS
THAT THERE IS PRO EXPRESSED
PROHIBITION AGAINST
DISCRIMINATION AGAINST VETERANS
ARE THOSE WHO HAVE SERVED -- IN
EMPLOYMENT -- CAN YOU EXPLAIN IN
YOUR OWN WORDS WHY THAT'S NOT
SUFFICIENT AND WHY THIS PIECE OF
LEGISLATION IS REQUIRED TO GO
BEYOND THAT EXPRESSED
PROHIBITION AGAINST
DISCRIMINATION TO NATIONAL
PREFERENCE.
AT THE END OF THE DAY.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THIS BILL?
IT WILL PROTECT THOSE EMPLOYERS
THAT WANT TO VOLUNTARILY GIVE
PREFERENCE TO VETERANS FROM
BEING SUED.
BY ANOTHER [inaudible]
GROUP.
THAT'S AT THE END OF THE DAY.
SO THIS IS NOT ANY KIND OF A OF
AGGRESSIVE WAY TO RECRUIT.
VETERANS SIMPLY TO PROTECT THEM
FROM A PROTECTED CLASS.
GOING AFTER A IN THIS IS A VERY
SMALL SUBSET.
OF OUR POPULATION.
THEY KERRY'S THE BURDEN OF
DEFENDING THE COUNTRY.
THANK YOU SIR BYE.
GREAT JOB -- THANK YOU AGAIN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF A POWER FOR
YOUR PRESENTATION AND I TO
SUPPORT VETERANS AND AND I
UNDERSTAND THE ONE OF THE BEST
THINGS WE NEED TO DO IS WORK
WITH THE PRIVATE SECTOR. TO GET
THEM JOBS I DO SHARE THE
CONCERNS ABOUT DISCRIMINATION I
THINK WE'LL VETERANS AS GROUP
WHERE WE CAN ALL AGREE -- THAT
WE NEED TO SUPPORT AND MAKE SURE
THEY GET JOBS I WOULD SAY WHAT
ABOUT WOMEN WHAT ABOUT YOU KNOW
PEOPLE WOMEN AND SCIENCE SHOULD
WE START GIVING ALLOWING A
VOLUNTARY PROGRAM -- FOR WOMEN
IN ON ON REPRESENT UNDER
REPRESENTED -- INDUSTRIES TO
HAVE LONG HAIR PROGRAMS THERE I
THINK WE GO DOWN THE SLIPPERY
SLOPE -- SO WHAT KIND OF
PRESIDENT DO YOU THINK THIS
WOULD SET FOR OTHER PROTECTED
CLASSES IF WE WORSHIP TO DO THIS
TODAY.
WELL THIRTY SEVEN OTHER STATES
HAVE BASICALLY THE SAME BILL.
THEY'VE HAD NO PROBLEMS
WHATSOEVER.
SO THAT PARTICULAR THIS
PARTICULAR SLIPPERY SLOPE
DOESN'T EXIST IN THIRTY SEVEN
STATES I DON'T SEE HOW
CALIFORNIA WOULD BE DIFFERENT.
RIGHT DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS.
SO WE HAD A MOTION BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SALAS AND A SECOND BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER OBERNOLTE.
OF MY I AM GOING TO SUPPORT THE
BILL TODAY -- I WAS I AND I KNOW
WHERE THAT THE OPPOSITION WAS --
I I HADN'T HEARD ABOUT IT BUT I
THINK THEY MAKE SOME OF THE VERY
THEY HAVE SOME VERY LEGITIMATE
CONCERNS AND SO THIS IS A
PROCESS IT AS IT MOVES TO THE
FLOOR AND THEN THROUGH THE
SENATE I HOPE THAT YOU WILL.
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THEM TO
SEE IF THERE IS A SOLUTION HERE.
WE'LL DO.
RIGHT CAN I HAVE THE SECRETARY
PLEASE TO THE ROLE.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS DELIVER
AND EMPLOYMENT IRWIN HI -- WHEN
I VOEPEL AYE VOEPEL AYE BURNER
MARTHA?
NAY.
BOERNER HORVATH NAY OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE AYE DALY.
DALY AYE FRAZIER.
FRAZIER I GLORIA.
GLORIA I MATHIS [inaudible]
MURATSUCHI [inaudible]
PETRIE-NORRIS.
PETRIE-NORRIS I SALAS.
SALAS AYE.
IT'S EIGHT TWO ONE RIGHT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER VOEPEL -- THAT
IS A TWO ONE IS TO PASS TO LABOR
AND EMPLOYMENT [inaudible]
RIGHT [inaudible]
RIGHTS -- YES WE'RE WE'RE GOING --
TO VOTE ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
RIGHT NOW AN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GARCIA YOU CAN GO AHEAD AND MAKE
YOUR WAY UP AS WE VOTE ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR.
AB TWENTY ONE DO COST
APPROPRIATIONS IN AB THIRTEEN
SIXTY FIVE TO PASS A JOBS AND
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT.
OKAY -- WHEN I -- WHEN I VOEPEL?
HELL I'D BURNER HORRIDA.
HI BOERNER HORVATH I OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE I A DAILY.
DALY AYE FRAZIER.
FRAZIER AYE GLORIA.
GLORIA AYE MATHIS [inaudible]
SUE CHANG [inaudible]
PETRIE-NORRIS.
PETRIE-NORRIS I SALAS
[inaudible]
ALICE I NINE ZERO AND THAT THAT
IS.
OUT.
OF OUR RIGHT WELCOME ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GARCIA AND YOU HAVE -- AB
FIFTY FIVE AND FRANK YOU I WANNA
SAY THERE'S NOTHING MORE
COMFORTING THAN WALKING INTO A
ROOM AND HAVE MISTER FRAZIER
LOOK AT YOU WITH A BIG SMILE. TO
SET [inaudible]
RIGHT.
AB FIFTY FIVE IS THE BILL THAT --
WE BRING BEFORE YOU TODAY THAT
WOULD -- ALLOCATE ELEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS TO OUR COUNTY VETERANS
SERVICE OFFICERS.
AT THIS PAST FALL WE ARE
FORTUNATE TO HAVE US SECRETARY
OF VETERANS AFFAIRS MISTER PETER
VETO M. SOLL SCHON ALL HOPE I I
PROBABLY DIDN'T SAY THAT RIGHT.
HAVE BUT BUT HE SAID CALLING
VETO SO WE HAD VETO -- IN OUR
DISTRICT -- EXPOSED TO SAY IT
LIKE THIS AND BOSS KIANA YEAH.
THERE YOU GO -- SO MY MY SPANISH
ACCENT PROBABLY WHEN GIVEN
JUSTICE -- AND SO.
WE MET WITH A HANDFUL OF VETERAN --
FOLKS REPRESENTING THE VARIOUS
COUNTIES AND OTHER ENTITIES
PROVIDING SERVICES FOR VETERANS.
AND THE CONVERSATION ABOUT --
REOCCURRING FUNDING -- WAS
BROUGHT UP.
AND THE AMOUNT -- THAT THE
MENTIONED GOING BACK TO TWO
THOUSAND NINE WAS AN ELEVEN
MILLION DOLLAR -- ALLOCATION
THAT UNFORTUNATELY NEVER CAME TO
FRUITION AND SINCE THEN --
ALLOCATIONS OF ABOUT TWO MILLION
HAVE BEEN MADE IN SOME INSTANCES
UP.
TO THE OVER FIVE MILLION.
WE KNOW THAT THIS MONEY PROVIDES
A SIGNIFICANT OPPORTUNITY FOR US
TO GO AFTER MONEY AT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT LEVEL. TWO THEN
EXPAND ON THE TYPE SERVICES THAT
THEY'RE ABLE TO PROVIDE ON THE
GROUND.
SO THAT IS THE BILL BEFORE YOU
IT IS ASKING FOR AN ELEVEN
MILLION DOLLAR ALLOCATION FOR
THE PURPOSE OF ENSURING THAT OUR
COUNTY VETERANS SERVICE OFFICERS.
HAVE THE NECESSARY.
RESOURCES AND THE NOW TO BOOT
PROVIDE THE CASE WORK THAT IS
NECESSARY. FOR THE VETERANS OF
CALIFORNIA -- WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YA VOTE
[inaudible]
THANK BILL.
ALL RIGHT ANOTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT DO.
AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
MY NAME IS SET THREE WITH THREE
GOVERNMENT RELATIONS -- AMVETS
DEPARTMENT CALIFORNIA.
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION COUNTY
VETERANS SERVICE OFFICERS
CALIFORNIA STATE COMMANDERS
VETERANS COUNCIL MILITARY
OFFICERS ASSOCIATION OF AMERICA
CALIFORNIA.
COUNCIL CHAPTERS NATIONAL GUARD
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA AND THE
VIETNAM VETERANS.
OF AMERICA CALIFORNIA STATE
COUNCIL ALL ARE ALL IN SUPPORT
OF THIS LEGISLATION.
THANK YOU.
AND I HAVE OTHER WITNESSES.
HEY MAN CHAIR AND A MEMBER OF
THE COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR THE
TIME I'M NATHAN JOHNSON I'M THE
FIRST VICE PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF COUNTY
VETERANS SERVICE OFFICERS.
ORGANIZATION THAT'S IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL I'M ALSO THE COUNTY
VETERANS SERVICE OFFICER FOR
CONTRA COSTA COUNTY -- AND WHICH
ARE SEMI MEMBER JIM FRAZIER IS%
THE THE REPRESENT OF NOT
DISTRICT -- I WANT TO MENTION IN
ADDITION TO THE ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
COMMENTS AND I THANK HIM FOR
INTRODUCING THIS BILL.
I WANT TO MENTION THAT THE ONE
POINT SEVEN MILLION VETERANS IN
THE STATE IS THE LARGEST
POPULATION OF VETERANS IN THE
NATION -- WHICH DO INCLUDE WOMEN --
AN ESTIMATED FOUR POINT TWO FIVE
MILLION FAMILY MEMBERS ARE ALSO
ELIGIBLE FOR THESE BENEFITS
BASED ON THE VETERANS SERVICE SO
THAT THE NUMBER ONE POINT SEVEN
IS IT IS A SIGNIFICANT UNDER
ESTIMATE OF HOW MANY PEOPLE.
THE COUNTY VETERANS SERVICE
OFFICERS TO SERVE.
I WANT TO MENTION IF I MAY HAVE
SAID JUST THE MORE TIME THAT --
PURSUING THESE BENEFITS HAS
BECOME SIMPLE SIGNIFICANTLY MORE
COMPLICATED RECENTLY.
AT THE VA THROUGH ITS PENSION
REFORM AND THROUGH THE APPEALS
MODERNIZATION ACT AND THROUGH
TODAY THE VA'S ANNOUNCEMENT THAT
THAT THEY WILL NOT FILE.
AN APPEAL ON THE RECENT --
COURT'S DECISION ON AGENT ORANGE
BENEFITS TO BLUE WATER NAVY
VETERANS -- THAT THE WORK FOR
CVS THOSE IS GOING TO BECOME
SIGNIFICANTLY MORE DEMAND AND
MORE COMPLICATED AND WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE THAT THESE AGENCIES
ARE PROPERLY FUNDED.
THE RETURN ON INVESTMENT.
INTO THIN FISCAL YEAR.
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN COUNTY
VETERANS SERVICE OFFICERS
BROUGHT IN OVER FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS IN FEDERAL
DOLLARS. TO OUR VETERANS INTO
THEIR FAMILY MEMBERS.
SO ELEVEN MILLION DOLLARS AND I
WISH I COULD TAKE A LEVINE NINE
DOLLARS INTERNET AND A FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION.
SIGN ME UP -- I DIED INVEST IN
THAT TODAY AND I KNOW ALL OF YOU
WOULD AS WELL -- AND LASTLY.
AB FIFTY FIVE IS NOT NECESSARILY
JUST ABOUT PROVIDE RESOURCES
ULTIMATELY.
IT'S ABOUT CONNECTING VETERANS
WITH BENEFITS THAT THEY HAVE
EARNED AND THAT THEY DESERVE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
YEAH FREDERICK ROMERO OF STATE
COMMANDER WITH AMERICAN JEFF
FORM WERE IN SUPPORT OF AB FIFTY
FIVE THANK YOU.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
QUESTION OF QUESTIONS YES.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR -- I HAD
THE DISTINCT PLEASURE OF A
WORKING WITH MISTER JOHNSON --
SEVERAL YEARS AGO ABOUT
AUGMENTING THE CVS SOS.
AND THEN ALSO BEING ABLE TO WORK
WITH HIM AS OF REFERRING SOME OF
MY CONSTITUENTS VETERANS.
ON THE ABILITY OF THE SEE IF YOU
CBS OWES ON WHAT THEY DO
ACCOMPLISH.
IS MIRACULOUS FOR THESE VETERANS
OF THERE ARE BEEN INSTANCES WHEN.
WE'VE HAD -- ISSUES ARE VETERANS
A WEREN'T SUPPORTED BY THE
EITHER CALVET OR THE VA.
AND THEY WENT TO BAT FOR THESE
VETERANS AND GOT THEM THE
BENEFITS THAT THEY DESERVE-- AS
THE AUTHOR OF THE VETERAN'S
DRIVER'S LICENSE A BILL -- AND
THE ABILITY TO BRING IN ALL OF
THOSE EXTRA BENEFITS FOR THOSE
VETERANS AND YOU TALK ABOUT.
THE FIVE HUNDRED SOMETHING
MILLION DOLLARS.
HAS BEEN DIRECTLY ATTRIBUTABLE
TO THE THE WORK OF THESE OF
INDIVIDUALS IN THE COUNTIES.
AND SO -- WITH THAT -- MISTER
SAID LOVE TO BE ADDED ON AS ANY
KIND OF HELP I CAN BE GOING ON
FUTURES FOR IS EITHER COAL.
OR ANY OTHER A PROCESS BUT THIS
IS DEFINITELY A WORTHY AMOUNT OF
MONEY BECAUSE OF WHAT -- THE
DATA GRATITUDE TO OUR VETERANS
THAT WE CAN NEVER REPAY.
THIS IS A SMALL SMALL TOKEN TO
BE ABLE -- TO RESPECT THEM.
I HAD TO HAVE ANY OTHER COMMENTS
FROM THE PANEL.
SO THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS AND WAS --
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRAZIER SECONDED
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER OBERNOLTE.
AND THE CLERK PLEASE TO THE ROLE --
WHEN I -- WHEN I VOEPEL?
VOEPEL I BURNER HORRIDA I
REMEMBER ABOUT THAT I OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE AYE DALY.
DALY AYE FRAZIER.
FRAZIER AYE GLORIA.
GLORIA AYE MATHIS.
MATHIS I MURATSUCHI.
PETRIE-NORRIS.
PETRIE-NORRIS I SALAS.
SALAS AYE.
CONGRATULATIONS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GARCIA.
AND LAST UP WE HAVE THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FLORA.
WITH THAT AB [inaudible]
FIVE FIFTY GOOD AFTERNOON.
STILL AFTERNOON THAT IS.
A GOOD SIGN.
ALL RIGHT I'LL MAKE THIS VERY
QUICK BECAUSE I KNOW WE'VE ALL
THAT.
GOT THINGS BUT I'M HERE TO
PRESENT AB FIVE FIFTY WHICH
WOULD ESTABLISH A MEDICAL FOSTER
HOMES PILOT PROGRAM.
MEDICAL FOSTER HOMES ARE.
NOT PERTAIN FOR ELIGIBLE
VETERANS TO LIVE IN AFFORDABLE
AND PRIVATE HOME ENVIRONMENT
RATHER THAN INSTITUTIONAL
SETTINGS INTEGRITY IN A SAFE
THIS PROGRAM'S PARTICIPANTS ARE
STRICTLY OVERSEEN BY THE US
DEPARTMENT VETERANS AFFAIRS.
AS WELL THE STATE COVERS STATE
AUDITOR'S.
CALIFORNIA FAMILIES ARE READY
AND WILLING TO OPEN THEIR HOMES
AND SERVE THOSE WHO HAVE SERVED
AB FIVE FIFTIES A PATHWAY TO
MAKE THAT POSSIBLE.
THIS BILL IS RECEIVED SUPPORT
FROM COPPER SO SHE'S OF HELL SIR
HEALTH SERVICES AT HOME AND THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION BETTER
VETERANS SERVICES AGENCIES WITH
THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE.
RIGHT ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
HI GREG HAYES HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
VETERANS SERVICE AGENCIES IN
SUPPORT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SEES ME FREDERICK CAMARO
COMMANDERS TAKE COMMAND OF
AMERICAN JEFF FORMER SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL.
THANK YOU ANY WITNESSES AND
OPPOSITION.
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
ALL RIGHTS THE A MOTION WAS OF
I'M SORRY.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER PETRIE-NORRIS.
HI I'M I BELIEVE THAT THIS AYE
THIS IS SIMILAR TO A BILL THAT
SAYS SOMEONE ELSE DID LAST
SESSION AND THERE WERE SOME
ISSUES WITH.
LIKE IT'S BACKGROUND CHECKS OR
SOMETHING TO THAT EFFECT.
IT ACTUALLY WAS ON CONSENT IN
THIS COMMITTEE LAST YEAR AND GOT
HELD APPROPRIATIONS ALCOHOL
SIMILAR BROWN AT LAST YEAR OKAY
RIGHT AND SO WE'RE HAVING A
WE'VE GOT THE RESOURCES TO
SUPPORT AT THE CITY.
OKAY GOT IT SO MUCH EASIER.
ALL RIGHT -- ANY OTHER.
THE LESS OF A QUESTION AND A
COMMENT I THINK THIS IS A GREAT --
ADDITIONAL TOLD TOOL IN OUR
TOOLBOX -- WE DO HAVE A LOT OF
AGING VETERANS AND NOT ENOUGH
WAYS TO CARE FOR THEM SO I THINK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR BRINGING IT
THIS FAR AND I'M HAPPY. TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
ALL RIGHT SO THE MOTION -- I'M
SORRY.
IT IS LIKE TO BE ADDED AS A CO
AUTHOR THE MOST.
BECAUSE YES SO THE MOTION BY%
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MATHIS'S A DO
PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS
SECONDED BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SALAS CAN OF THE CLERK PLEASE TO
THE WORLD -- WHEN I -- WHEN I
VOEPEL?
VOEPEL I BOERNER HORVATH I
REMEMBER THAT I OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE AYE DALY.
DALY I FRAZIER.
FRAZIER AYE GLORIA AYE AYE
GLORIA AYE MATHIS.
MATHIS I A MURATSUCHI.
PETRIE-NORRIS.
PETRIE-NORRIS I SALAS.
SALAS. NINE TEN ZERO THAT BILLS
OUT CONGRATULATIONS THE MANAGER.
ALL RIGHT AND WE ARE GOING TO
HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FOR ANOTHER
FIVE MINUTES BUT WHY DON'T WE GO
THROUGH THE MEMBERS THAT --
ARRIVED A LITTLE BIT LATE HAVE
AN ADD ON OKAY DO YOU MIND DOING
THAT ON THE NIGHT.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MATHIS THE
CONSENT CALENDAR HI.
MATHIS AYE.
AND THEN -- HI.
AB.
TWENTY TWO SORRY.
THAT'S IT YOU'RE GOOD
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
ALL.
DO YOU WANT TO GO FOR THE
ADOPTION OF RULES.
NO.
I I WANT TO VOTE NO ON THE
OPTION OF THANK YOU.
MEN'S WOMEN'S SAME I'M MATHIS
AYE IT ON THE SO ARE YOU YEAH
THE CITY. ONE OF THE WITH THIS
PERSON
[inaudible]
YEAH.
AROUND THE WORLD WITH
[inaudible]
WE GOT
RIGHT.
OF JUST GRABBED A MICROPHONE.
CAN THE CONSENT CALENDAR AB
TWENTY ONE IN THIRTEEN SIXTY
FIVE MURATSUCHI.
MURATSUCHI I AB FIFTY FIVE
GARCIA WE'RE TEACHING BY
RESEARCHING.
NINE AB ONE SIXTY VOEPEL VERSE.
FIFTEEN RECEIVED YEAH I IN THE
AB FIVE FIFTY FLORA MERCY TEAM.
WE'RE CITY I RULES IN THE ROLE --
WHERE THIRTEEN FIVE CITY ON?
FRIDAY.
VERY MUCH OF THIS MEETING IS
ADJOURNED